Japanese woman like Asian women like
Asian girls grandmas they are savages
they are not afraid of anything like Oh
They'll kill you yeah they will but my
mom almost killed me many times many
[__] times the the Asian moms yeah
yeah I think they're like black grandmas
black grandmas don't [__] with them
yeah they are so tough and people think
women are weak my mom used to do this
thing
wait I do that too you hate it
and when my mom did that I knew I was
gonna get a bruise somewhere on my body
God right it was so scary ask my brother
we were petrified like one time I was I
went to painted Rock Elementary School
all right and I I farted
um in class purposely right and I and I
go I think no I think the teacher goes
well do you guys know that this answer
and I go I do and then she goes what is
it and I go when they farted right nice
body outside and so I had to sit outside
the classroom right and so when the door
opens there's uh something a painted
thing around the the cement to show you
where the door is and I sat inside that
[__] Circle right so the principal
walks up and goes um
can you sit you know I mean beside the
door and not around the circle you don't
the door doesn't swing and hit somebody
hit me right I wanted to get maimed
right and so um I go no and he goes I'm
gonna count to three I remember this I'm
gonna count to three and he goes one two
and I go three right then I remember
them call my mom my mom her cheeks were
inside her throat
right right
and I just remember and I just knew
beating it was the worst beating I've
ever had your mom hit you yeah
I mean she didn't hear me uh she hit me
with the chair she was throwing things
on me yeah
they don't do it like to teach you a
lesson they want an imprint yeah you
know they don't spank there's no such
thing as a spankings yeah yeah they want
you to remember it 30 years later yeah
just belt like my dad was hit me with
his belt yeah yeah yeah like it when
you're walking around your knees lock
yeah yeah I mean and you're 50 and
someone goes what happened on my mom
when I was eight because this is like
the dictionary she's a reduction
a minus yes yeah yeah my mom would have
us like watch her eat a banana on the
table and you knew that like her eyes
were already like you know her face was
covering in her age and she would slowly
eat the banana and then when the banana
was done she would like whip our faces
with a banana across the table
yeah that's like a villain from James
Bond
poor version and would you cry yeah yeah
you're right but we were frozen in fear
it's not like we could just run away
she's like fast and athletic she could
just you know catch us and he does even
harder yeah you just sit there and know
in anticipation that there's a banana
lashing like about to happen but you
know what I do in that situation
I double down on it and while she's
swinging I put my face into it oh Jesus
you mean like you know I mean like
you're out of protest I'm that guy yeah
do it you're a martyr I want more I'm a
martyr dude against the rights of the
Asian moms exactly Star Wars I don't
like any kind of Oppression I don't like
any kind of that kind of vibe dude I
mean like you know I mean yeah abuse of
power I don't cry because she's gonna be
happy if I cry exactly I just don't it's
the same thing it's the same thing we
knew but then my sister was really smart
she was like kalila the trick is I was
like why did she beat you less she's
like I cry immediately it stops the
meeting my sister same way yeah my
sister the same way and I was the one
who's like give me more yeah yeah yeah
we [__] up we [__] up hey we cried
you wish to cry we should take a
messenger and the like method acting
class yeah exactly right oh my God
that's so we're jumping before my sister
was the same way as your sister they
should be friends they should be because
she was like cry cry also asked Mario
right whenever she argue with me she
can't get what she wants she slap her
face she wrote my message
she just do that you know what Steve did
he called Social Services wow that's a
it's a very white move it's a very my
brother was very white Caucasian no
because he went to church while he was a
Christian okay and I think he went to
church right and they're like well what
you got to do is you gotta call this
number this and that beat it my brother
did it right and I remember like nothing
happened to my brother I somehow got the
beauty haha he probably told your mom
that you gave him the number oh that's
but remember younger ones are smarter
than us all right yeah my brother was a
little Survivor but I got the beating
for that dude and I didn't do anything
the other ones are evil the last beating
I ever got was when I was 14 or 15. we
um it was the first time we ever went to
an American Mall we'd only been in
America for like a month and we went bra
shopping at JCPenney and I was too
afraid my mom said go ask for your size
and I was like I I was so scared to ask
the sales lady I was like can you do it
and she's like I'm not gonna do it and
there was like a back and forth and dude
my mom like took one tit for my sister
and one tit for me and she like titty
twistered both of us and she had bruised
little titties like on her way home and
then finally my sister was like you do
that one more time like this is America
like I'm gonna [__] call call but we
went home with Bruce titties because she
just [__] in public at JCPenney just
like turned their tits this way you know
what you do you buy two pepperonis
for the next time right and when she
twists your titties you can go
okay him off that's what I would do all
right because because
at that point she'll feel guilty right
she'll like freak the [__] out or she's
like why are you holding pepperoni right
right right right maybe imagine having
blue nipples for a week in your first
[__] month in America you're like my
titties are blue oh my God it's so sad
so [__] up it's so [__] up yeah I'm
glad there's rules in place yeah or [__]
like that man but um I don't even know
but you know what
I'm grateful for all of it aren't you or
no because I I know I find out it's not
equal to video Kids In America when we
become parent he really think like if I
can beat them oh but you can't do it in
America in America no so your kids have
they behaved in ways where you kind of
wanted to do something or no
um my son he's the kind of you know